this isn't a novel therapy. It's more of a predictive and prognostic thing that we're
looking at that might be explaining why some patients have a deep response in both CAR-T
therapy and bispecific therapy. So we all know we've had fantastic responses still to cell
patients having what could be considered a cure now with five years of aggression-free survival
or greater, but there are still patients that do not have that response. And we did a deep dive to
see what was causing that. And we published a paper and other individuals said it too,
that at month one, there might be myeloid suppression that's in preventing this long
durable response in patients. So if you see here in the red, at month one, there's an expansion
of these myeloid-derived suppressor cells that is present in patients that do not have a PFS
of greater than five years. And when we looked at the gene expression profile of those myeloid,
of MDSCs, we found that they were, we found that they were enriched for S100A8 and A9 gene
expression. And S100A8 and A9 is a calprotectin. It's a damage-associated molecular protein.
It's produced by myeloid cells, stromal cells, and mesenchyne cells. And it acts as an alarmin.
It promotes more MDSCs and actually expansion of T-regulatory T-cells, T-regulatory cells,
and in general creates an immunosuppressive microenvironment. And this has been known
to be elevated in blood cancer, such as myeloma, and it's associated with negative prognosis.
So we wanted to validate this in our patients. So we took a separate cohort of patients. We took
four patients that had rapid progression or median PFS of less than nine days and compared
those to had a durable response. And we looked at soluble,
S100 levels in the peripheral blood. And we can see at month one, we have the rapid
regression is having a significantly higher presence of this S100A8, A9. And when we looked
at the immune microenvironment, they actually also had higher T-regs, higher MDSCs. And more
importantly, we couldn't find circulating CAR-T. So there's truncated CAR-T expansion in these
patients. We thought, is this specific to CAR-T or is this for all T-cell-directed therapies?
We moved to look at this in our bispecific treated patients. So we took a cohort of 19 patients here
and we looked at S100 levels at baseline.
And during therapy, what we can see is that the patients who did not achieve, who had greater than
a VGPR had significantly lower S100 levels in the blood at both baseline and then during
bispecific therapy around cycle three, day one. So patients who had a deep response had significantly
lower S100. When we looked at it in terms of progression-free survival, we looked at the
median between those who had high and less high and low S100. We found that the patients who had
higher S100 had significantly lower progression-free survival. And in general,
the levels of S100 in the peripheral blood correlated negatively with PFS. So more S100,
less progression-free survival in our patients. So we wanted to see, did that affect the T-cells
of our patients who have a short PFS? So we did a immunophenotyping and looked to see,
are there any changes within the T-cell microenvironment in these patients?
First thing we looked at was TOCS, which is a transcriptional factor that's known to be in
exhausted cells and does drive general exhaustion markers at PD1 and CD39. And we found that the
short PFS in general had higher presence of these CD3 TOCS cells. When we used spatial
transpectomics, we actually found that the myeloid cells that had S100 co-localized with
exhausted T-cells. So in the corner in the yellow, you see these blue myeloid cells that
are S100 negative, and they're co-localizing to T-cells that are also TOCS negative. While in the
red, you see the yellow myeloid cells that express S100, and they co-localize to these
purple TOCS positive T-cells, indicating that there is enrichment of these myeloid cells to
exhausted T-cells.
And when we do correlations again, we see that in general, progression-free survival
negatively correlates with TOCS presence. So less progression-free survival with more of
these cells that have higher TOCS, and S100 correlated significantly with the amount of
TOCS cells. Now we wanted to make sure, because there's a lot of debate of what is an exhausted
cell, we want to make sure that this TOCS expression correlated with actual functionality.
So we took our patient cells, we actually co-cultured them with myeloma cells and
teclistamab, and we wanted to see, does this lead to reduced cytotoxicity?
And what we ended up seeing is that just like in the TOCS presence, the patients who had short
PFS actually had significantly lower cytotoxicity in our in vitro culture. And like we saw before,
this correlated actually with the amount of TOCS cells and the amount of S100. So you had less
cytotoxicity with the more presence of these TOCS positive cells, and you had less cytotoxicity with
the amount of S100 that was there. So we wanted to validate this in vitro.
We wanted to make sure that this is a direct effect and not just a correlation. So we took
healthy donor,
PBMCs, and then derived CAR-Ts from them and incubated them 72 hours with S100. And then we
captured dynamic changes. In the interest of time, I'm not going to show it, but they did increase in
TOCS levels and they actually did differentiate more into T regulatory cells. But functionally,
on the top here, you see that cytotoxicity and both CAR-T cytotoxicity were dose-dependently
inhibited by the amount of S100 that we cultured them for time.
So the more S100 that we added to the media, the less cytotoxicity the cells
were in vitro. So what we end up getting is a system where you have this immunosuppressive
ligand that's attaching, influencing CAR-T cells and T cells and making them not able to attack
the myeloma cell. So in conjunction with Albert Einstein Medicine and Amit Verna and
Roshan Therapeutics, they actually formulated a monoclonal antibody that blocks the binding of
S100 to all of its receptors. And we tested this in vitro in our ongoing studies in vivo to see if
this does actually recapitulate the response that we had and prevent T cell dysfunction.
So this is some of the results that we have from there. On the left, you have healthy derived CAR-T
cells that were incubated, again, 72 hours with S100. And on the right, you have peripheral blood
mononuclear cells that were incubated 72 hours. And then in the blue is with nothing added. In
the red, you have the inhibitory effect that we're mentioning S100 has on the T cells and CAR-T cells.
And then strikingly, the pink is the salvage that's done when you add the monoclonal antibody to prevent
this T cell exhaustion. And then on the right, you have the monoclonal antibody that was incubated
to prevent this T cell exhaustion. And again, I'm not including a lot of this, but you do see a lot of
less differentiation of T cells when you add this monoclonal, less differentiation of T regulatory
cells when you add this monoclonal antibody. In the immune microbiome, you also have less
differentiation of myeloid derived suppressor cells. So you, in general, you have a less
immunosuppressive microenvironment. So with this, I just want to conclude by saying that we are
seeing that S100-88 and A9 does predict inferior depth of response in patients, especially those
who are receiving T cell-directed therapy. And we're seeing that S100-88 does predict inferior depth of
response in patients, especially those who are receiving T cell-directed therapy. It promotes the
increase of tox, reduced cytokine production, which I don't show here, but it did have a universal
decrease of cytokine, antigen-specific cytokine production, and cytotoxicity. And when you
neutralize it using a monoclonal antibody, you can actually salvage this T cell dysfunction,
making it a strong therapeutic target for not just multiple myeloma, but all T cell-directed therapy.
And with that, I want to thank everyone for all that.